j'ai eu des douleurs dans les bras mais
je n'en sais pas plus inquiétés et après
au bout de deux trois heures j'ai une
grosse douleur au niveau thoracique et
tout s'est enchaîné presse chaque colis
dieu j'en ai trop dit que j'allais
mourir
et puis j'ai mis une semaine un mois ou
m j'avais une vie saine j'ai jamais fait
mais je vois pas je fais du sport
et tiens ça te prend le dessus c'est
comme au loto
j'ai gagné le samu pour tous les appels
arrivent ici à la régulation du centre
du simple mal de ventre au début d'un
sac tus les permanenciers sont à
l'écouté des symptômes il et
transcrivent rapidement pour un premier
bilan et doivent déterminer en quelques
minutes s'il s'agit d'une urgence
cardiaque
oui monsieur c'est le samu il faut que
vous soyez vue sur les urgences madame
et il n'y a pas de médecins qui se
déplacent ils sont débordés ils se
déplacent pas par exemple faites vous le
patient dit j'ai une douleur thoracique
là tout de suite on sait que voilà on va
dire on va poser des questions pour cent
en savoir un petit peu plus et après on
voit avec notre régulateur
hélas le régulateur nous dit si on
envoie une ambulance des pompiers ou un
smur selon la gravité que le médecin
reçoit en cas de crise cardiaque le
facteur temps est très important les
secours doivent intervenir dans les 15 à
20 minutes
michael a l'habitude de ce type
d'intervention et travaille au samu
depuis 18 ans il a vu l'âge et le profil
des patients évolué
15 20 ans en dessous de 60 70 ans
c'était rarement un infarctus ou
maintenant l'évolution fait que
ça que j'ai des jambes plus jeunes
après 30 ans ça peut être plus cher
mais bon c'est des choses vous voyez pas
forcément
et la prise en charge commence par un
examen des coronaires ce sont les
artères qui entoure le coeur je vais
injecter un produit dans votre art
heures ça va brûler un peu grâce à un
liquide opaque diffusé dans les artères
le cardiologue peut voir directement sur
l'écran si elles sont bouchées ou non
parce qu'ils allaient tranquillement ont
écouté des nouvelles sont bonnes y a pas
d'artère bouchée aucune donc les
douleurs dans la poitrine
s'ils ne font pas des crises d'angine de
poitrine
tant mieux ce patient a été prise en
charge rapidement grâce au système des
urgences cardiaques
un moyen de remédier au manque de
cardiologues ont été adressées donc par
son médecin généraliste qui l'a vu en
consultation
hier soir qu'ils étaient inquiets et qui
connaît notre système de assez réactif
on peut voir les patients en urgence
sans prise de rendez vous tous les
matins du lundi au samedi matin
si l'artère est bouché on pose d'un
stent un petit tuteur en alliage
métallique comme celui ci qui valent à
consolider permettre au sang de circuler
normalement
puis le patient passe en soins intensifs
sa fréquence cardiaque y est surveillé
jour et nuit est ce qu'il ya des
douleurs particulières non pour vous
sentez bien d'accord donc là pour
l'électro cardiogramme vous bouger plus
et vous parlez plus un
ici le turnover est important la
douzaine de lits peut se remplir en une
seule nuit
le service accueille les patients de
l'indre et du cher en urgence la
cardiologie réalise 2000 diagnostic émis
son intervention par an soit le même
nombre que aussi à chu de tours alors
faire un petit peu mieux un chiffre en
augmentation malgré les discours de
prévention
pourtant les facteurs de risque sont
connus tabac diabète cholestérol et
manque d'exercice alors pour réamorcer
le coeur le cardiologue la prescrire un
stage de rééducation
souvent les gens vont tellement mieux
qu'ils sont étonnés de devoir rester à
l'hôpital quelques jours de devoir a
préféré de rééducation cardiaque mais
ils ne se rendent pas compte qu'ils sont
passés à côté à côté de la mort souvent
les gens sont un petit peu réticent
initialement pour aller en rééducation
parce que on leur dit quatre semaines
donc c'est
deux semaines hors du domicile donc
initialement ils sont pas très motivés
après on leur explique que c'est du
lundi matin au vendredi après midi donc
ils vont rentrer chez eux le week-end
pour souffler un petit peu et quand ils
reviennent quand on les revoit en
consultation tous sont enchantés par ce
qu'ils se sont aperçus qu'ils peuvent
reprendre une vie normale sans crainte
qu'il peut faire beaucoup plus de choses
grâce à l'exercice physique fait avec
les kinésithérapeutes les médecins les
infirmières les professeurs d'éducation
physique et c'est une trentaine de
patients participent à ce stage de
quatre semaines à l'hôpital
et ça commence par l'apprentissage de la
respiration
donc on va bien se relâcher sur les
tapis ou les tables en gardant une
position jambes fléchies pour tout le
monde pour bien protéger son dos
on va souffler par la bouche en creusant
son ventre puis respirer par le nez en
gonflant son ventre nous essayer tous
aller au plus loin dans les volumes tout
en restant dans un espace confort
essayez d'imaginer le ballon qui se
gonfle à l'intérieur lorsque vous
remplissez et qui se vide lorsque vous
souffler
tous les patients sont assidus
respectent les consignes apprennent à
écouter leur coeur pour eux c'est en
tournant un changement de vie qui se
profile c'est ce que constatent les
affaires à la gare responsable de la
rééducation cardiaque à l'hôpital
c'est l'accident cardiaque qui déclenche
le déclic chez le patient il le sait
tout ça bien sûr les laisser aimer et il
pense qu il va pas m'arriver à moi est
d'aller vos ordres d'accord mais le fait
d'avoir un accident
c'est le moment le patient est l'un des
clics et paix et le suivre à notre nous
recommande à sion pour l'échauffement
on y va
ce n'est pas un cours d'aquagym comme
les autres soufflez bouger c'est un
impératif après un accident cardiaque
ces exercices dans l'eau vont les aider
à faire accélérer le rythme sans se
rendre compte on essaye de travailler en
endurance sur la durée de faire monter
la fréquence cardiaque d'accord est
derrière moi ce qui m'agace d'autres
exercices et leur capacité de
récupération au niveau de la fréquence
cardiaque le coeur va monter à l'effort
mais nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
savoir derrière comment il récupère si
leur coeur mais plutôt une minute à
récupérer une scie mais trois minutes la
science dure une heure en petits groupes
de niveau impossible de ne pas exécuter
sérieusement chaque mouvement
la tension est prise avant et après
l'effort pour éviter toute récidive
allez fais partie la gymnastique fait
aussi partie de ce programme un
programme progressif au début les
patients ne font que cinq mouvements
puis il monte en puissance jusqu'à 15
répétition pour réapprendre à souffler
et à faire travailler leur coeur des
mouvements simples
le but est aussi de montrer que
l'activité physique peut se pratiquer
partout et même rejoints avec les
petits-enfants et qu'un balai
c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant
aussi des trucs avec un ballon d'un
parfois à se retrouver en difficulté
même si on était avec un enfant de trois
ans on va chercher là-bas la lance et
tous les jours c'est un peu mieux mais
puis dans 15 jours je sors et je fais le
marathon de new york sur demain ça vous
a donné envie de continuer le sport
ensuite j'en ai fait énormément dans ma
vie du sport
alors heureusement ce sinon je serais
plus là j'ai fait j'ai fait quinze ans
de karaté j'ai fait du plongeon et la
natation je fais de la course à pied et
jeu unique à tous un paquet de
cigarettes par jour
hélas au programme également l'atelier
culinaire les patients apprennent à
cuisiner autrement moins gras moins salé
mais avec du goût et surtout avec
quelques astuces comme cette sauce
béchamel alléger le jeu il lé dessus
en feuilletant bien rigoureuse mans et
voyez ça nous fait une consistance de
béchamel sa choisi de la faire sans
beurre voilà parce qu'on a utilisé le
but 20 de notre atelier c'est aussi de
faire une cuisine pas trop riche en
graisses mais montrer des technico aux
patients au menu également poisson en
papillote et tout le monde met la main à
la pâte en respectant les conseils et
les recettes de la diététicienne et moi
ce que j'ai pu avec du beurre bon
matériel
là c'est une autre façon tu dis c'est
bien c'est pg je pense déjà là au bout
d'une semaine je perçus quand même que
je me sens déjà mieux en point de vue
physiquement un peu mieux voilà bah
écoutez je vous souhaite un bon appétit
à tous prenaient le temps de manger
prenez le temps c'est important de
prendre le temps de manger de déguster
de bien sentir les saveurs ne pas manger
à toute vitesse
ça permet de moins manger et ça permet
de mieux digérer plus de savourer quoi
les choses on est d'apprécier j'ai pas
ce que vous en pensez
ben mon appétit
[Musique]
dans l'activité de marche fait partie
d'une activité activité d'endurance
comme ce que vous faites à l'intérieur
lorsque vous faites du vélo
là on va tourner touche en circuit fermé
à un moment donné vous allez regarder
votre cardiofréquencemètre à chaque fois
vous allez vous rendre à ce point là
comme en gymnastique d'accord et à la
fin de l'activité marche on va vous
demander de mémoriser la valeur la plus
haute de toutes les marches déjà ça
c'est une chose donc vérification du
cardio fréquencemètre pascal a subi un
changement de sa valve aortique et porte
un pacemaker
à 59 ans il redécouvre les joies de la
marche et améliore sa résistance
cardiaque et je respire beaucoup mieux
qu'avant
il avait dû cohésion sont à fait déjà du
bien à vous trois semaines sous la dent
le faux j'ai fait trois tours je crois
là qu'un jour de femmes oui et là je
suis à mon cinquième tour est beaucoup
moins soufflé au dessus mais une dizaine
de cigarettes par jour
je suis moi je travaille de nuit je veux
goûter de nuit est là depuis le mois
d'octobre est pour l'instant j'ai
partout sur une cigarette et puis je
pense que ça va depuis quoi je subviens
chacun avance à son rythme
même si les niveaux sont différentes 7
sept heures de marche plusieurs fois par
semaine permettent aussi d'entraîner
tout le groupe
les anciens accompagné nouveau
introduisent les
les accueils et puis après c'est un
turnover en permanence et ils viennent
de tout horizon que ce soit
professionnels médicaux surtout avec des
pathologies complètement différente de
tout âge et ça se passe toujours très
bien les plus les plus costauds en train
des mois les plus faibles et puis tout
le monde y trouve son compte et les plus
faibles viennent plus costaud et ainsi
de suite
[Musique]
à la fin du stage
les patients ne sont pas abandonnés à
leur sort ils reçoivent les conseils
d'une kinésithérapeute
tous les sujets sont abordés sans tabous
si vous continuez régulièrement une
activité physique d'un minimum comme je
vous ai dit de 30 minutes trois fois
minimum trois fois par semaine un
minimum de 30 minutes à chaque fois à
votre fréquence cardiaque
sans oublier les 5-10 minutes d'entre
d'eux d'échauffement au démarrage et 5
10 minutes de récupération
et bien tout ce que vous avez
actuellement va être modifié parce que
vous allez continuer à progresser
vous savez que la montée de deux étages
réalisé sans difficulté vous permet une
activité sexuelle avec votre partenaire
je dis bien habituel parce que toute
nouvelle relation peut engendrer plus de
stress émotionnel
tous sont attentifs car à leur sortie
ils ne seront plus sous surveillance
médicale
ils doivent apprendre à vivre avec leur
maladie et amplifier les bénéfices du
stage me suis aperçu les
assouplissements les petits exercices
physiques ont fait voilà je m'aperçois
que je me lève le matin fuite ou
courbatures et puis en fin de compte dès
qu'on commence à un quart d'heure après
je suis souple comme un jeune homme
comme une gazelle
je vous dis pas la tête de la gueule à
menton chez de moi j'essaie d'heure
qu'on le dit comme ça
avant faire du sport me faisais et puis
avoir une activité en fonction des
possibilités mais physique mais pour
savoir jusqu'où tu peux aller quoi ah
ben ça m'a beaucoup aidé franchement la
maison je fais rien du tout moi je te le
vélo d'appartement temps en temps je le
fais mais pas souvent dans le groupe ça
vous a oui je suis même triste de sortir
j'ai le coeur je retiens mes larmes
il leur faudra six mois à un an
avant de retrouver une vie normale
aujourd'hui la crise cardiaque est la
première cause de mortalité pour les
hommes et les femmes en france
un malade sur trois qui a suivi ce stage
de rééducation cardiaque ne vous choque
pas